وصف الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن سلوك الرد
الاسرائيلي في قطع غزه بانه تجاوز الحد
واضاف انه يعمل من اجل التوصل الى وقف
مستدام للقتال كما قال بايدن خلال كلمه في
البيت الابيض ان الرئيس المصري لم يرد في
البدايه بطلبات فتح بوابه معبر رفح لدخول
المساعدات الى غزه فتحدث معه بايدن واقنعه
بفتحها كما تحدث حينها الى رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي لتهيئه فتح البوابه من الجانب
الاخر كما تعلمون فانني ممن يرون ان طريقه
الرد الاسرائيلي في غزه تجاوزت الحد
واعتقد كما تعلمون ان الرئيس المصري
السيسي لم يريد في البدايه ان يفتح بوابه
المعبر للسماح بدخول المساعدات الانسانيه
الى غزه تحدثت معه واقنعته بفتح البوابه
وتكلمت مع بمين نتنياهو لفت فتح المعبر من
الجانب
الاسرائيلي كما قال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن انه كان على اتصال مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو من اجل السماح
بادخال المساعدات الى غزه موضحا انه ضغط
بشده من اجل ذلك وشدد بايدن خلال كلمه في
البيت الابيض على ان ما يعانيه الابرياء
في غزه من الجوع يجب ان
يتوقف تحدثت مع بنيامين نتنياهو لفتح
بوابه المعبر من الجانب الاسرائيلي لقد
كنت اضغط كل الضغط وبقوه من اجل ايصال
الغوث الانساني الى غزه الكثير من
الابرياء يتضورون جوعا وفي ورطه ويموتون
ويجب ان يتوقف ذلك انا الرجل الذي اوضح
انه يتعين علينا بذل المزيد من الجهد
لزياده كميه المواد التي تدخل غزه بما في
ذلك الوقود والمواد
الاخرى كما تحدث بايدن في خطاب البيت
الابيض عن اتصاله مع المسؤولين القطريين
والمصريين من اجل ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه واضاف انه ظل يضغط
بشده من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق للهدنه
يتضمن اطلاق سراح الرهائن
كنت على اتصالات هاتفيه مع القطريين
والمصريين وكذلك مع السعوديين لايصال اكبر
قدر ممكن من المساعدات الى غزه حث الناس
ابرياء نساء واطفا وفي حاجه ماسه الى
المساعدات ونحن ندفع بهذا الاتجاه انني
اضغط كل الضغط للتوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار
بشان الرهائن وكما تعلمون فقد كنت اعمل
بلا كلل من اجل هذا الاتفاق اعمل من اجل
اتفاق يؤدي الى توقف مستدام للقتال في ظل
الاحداث التي تجري في قطاع
غزه